شهر على هذا الحال السودان يختنق فوضى لم
تفرق حرب لم تصدها حصانه ولا دبلوماسيه
تعدت اسوار السفارات والملحقات الثقافيه
الاردن المتضرر الاخير اعلن اقتحام وتخريب
مقر سفارته في الخرطوم
اما في السادس من مايو حادثه اعتداء على
موكب تابع للسفاره التركيه لدى الخرطوم
قبل اقل من اسبوعين شهدت الملحقيه
الثقافيه السعوديه في السودان اقتحاما
واستيلاء على ممتلكاتها
وابل من الرصاص تعرضت له سياره مصفحه تتبع
للسفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم
كما جرى الاعتداء على مقر اقامه سفير
الاتحاد الاوروبي في السودان
فيما تعرض مقر البعثه الدبلوماسيه
الفرنسيه لهجوم ادى الى تاجيل اجلاء رعايه
فرنسيين
اطلاق الاعيره الناريه طال ايضا السفاره
الهنديه
حوادث الاعتداء على السفارات هذه عاده ما
كانت توربكو عمليات الاجلاء او تؤجلها غير
انها شاهده على خرق واضح لهدن لم تعرف
للصمود طريقا غذاء السالم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات